it's been a day of rain and rescue with
little respite roads are traps this
flood water is deep it smells and it's
dangerous boats were the only way out
for these men and rather amande South
Yorkshire who got stuck at work
overnight no we leave him come safely
meaning at one point he was about six
foot deep companyís or there were no
where we were leaving say if I was
asleep or and wait for services really
this is what two days of nearly constant
rain looks like parts of South and West
Yorkshire Lincolnshire and Greater
Manchester have all been affected across
South Yorkshire the flooding has been
quite localized but very very intense
the water came in so quickly that some
people got stuck as they were trying to
get through meaning they've had to
abandon their vehicles nearby businesses
and homes have been evacuated and the
bad news is that it is still raining in
Doncaster the local river spilled over
flooding properties with little warning
people grabbed what they could a permit
space of an hour started for a trick of
and all of a sudden small attack window
when they were there about a nine this
morning and there were nothing darlings
Road what's love it will completely
clear that we're not even a puddle I
know about I say in this place for 20
minutes
many rail services across the north of
England have been canceled or delayed in
Rotherham and South Yorkshire passengers
got onto a bus but had to get off on a
dinghy vehicles of all shapes and all
sizes were no match for the floods but
only being temporary tell you mean like
a little dive through you know but if
afternoon or nothing like this in South
Yorkshire the floods have been declared
a major incident fire crews have had
more than 1200 emergency calls
we've had flooding starting Sheffield
which is progres Surrey - rather room
it's now in Doncaster the river levels
have been as high as they were in 2007
when we have the serious Bloods but from
Derbyshire came the worst news that a
woman from Rose Lee drowned after being
swept away in floodwater no one here
realized it would be so bad so fast it
was horrendous it was flooded out my
garden was like a lake next door's
garden was 2 or 3 feet high weren't it
Helen there was dust bins coming down
the road II oh listen the car is the
Prime Minister came to Derbyshire this
evening to nearby Matlock Boris Johnson
joined in an impromptu cleanup and
promised help but some will question why
after so much money has been invested in
flood defences this rain has had such an
impact we are seeing more more serious
very fast because of building perhaps
because of almost certainly because of
climate change we need to prepare and we
need to be investing in those defenses
the rain is expected to clear a little
this evening but weather warnings are
still in place and the cleanup has only
just begun Katarina verticies Sky News
in Rotherham South Yorkshire